the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think a bobble is our story because
bobble is our story what's it really
there's some fascinating aspects to it
but one of the most fascinating is some
of the things that he's said that people
said was horseshit is told has been
proven to be true like one of the things
the the biometric reader that measured
the length of the bones in your hand and
that they're unique as unique as a
fingerprint and you're like what are you
talking about that this was something
they really did have and they have
photos of this thing now this is
something he talked about and they
claimed it was science fiction
I mean it's fascinating when someone
touches upon a subject that the
government does not want known about for
any reason and there is a campaign to
discredit that person you know there's
no doubt that that happened to him I
mean it was remarkable and I write about
him in the book because if you follow
the logic that my source told me that
these were you know modified human
beings as part of a hoax and the reason
that I trust the source is because Joe
he told me that he also worked on the
program so he had like a burden to
unload right and so if you follow that
logic through then the bobble is our
story is that Bob when Bob Lazar said I
saw an alien it looked like this it was
small it had big eyes it's yes those
were the jannat genetically I mean those
were the surgically modified humans that
the government was doing experiments on
I think Bob lazarre's exact quote was he
walked by a window and he looked in he
saw two agents that were it looked they
were looking down at something that was
very small and looked humanoid but he
didn't know if it was a dummy or
anything and he wasn't even supposed to
be looking in there and it was a brief
like one-second look that he is bounced
around in his head back and forth has it
ever occurred to you that maybe the guy
who gave that information did work there
but is also feeding you horseshit well
the source was a major player in the
Manhattan Project he went on and worked
in the Atomic Energy Commission I mean
there's a wing of a museum named after
his accolades his awards were so
extraordinary it would please him I've
never said his name although you know I
will say this well you're giving her
away like giving away a lot of the stuff
he recently died and he did give me
permission to tell his full story after
he died and I'm circling around that I'm
circling around that but he was
absolutely a you know with a Q clearance
that's what you have when you have
access to nuclear secrets so if someone
has a Q clearance for decades and
they're full of garbage you really have
to ask my god should this guy have a Q
clearance I mean that's reverse
engineering his credibility but I think
you should read the whole book because
you know it's shocking what he says but
it does make sense if you can get
through four hundred pages of you know
the CIA's idea about information
disinformation why we need to cover
things up why that's why I'm asking if
you think that he's he might have been
lying to you
I don't believe what's elaboration know
I don't believe I don't believe so you
think that the Stalin that the Russian
government definitely did surgically
alter people to make them look like
aliens
I believe were their images I believe
what he told me did you see photos no
but here's the rub ready okay when I was
writing another book called phenomena
which dealt with the CIA and the
Pentagon's use of psychics okay mm-hmm
over decades I mean this goes back
everything I write about pretty much
goes back to post-world War with no
remote viewing stuff yes yes and it's
all about government u.s. government
takes pole position after World War two
and we now need to always be ahead of
the curve we must lead we can never get
beaten by the Russians now it's China
okay so the psychic program had a lot of
people who really believe in aliens or
you know other Intel intelligence from
other worlds and when I was writing the
phenomena book I learned a whole bunch
of new information about how upset they
were with my story because they Baloo
the source by the way they knew the
source and
believed that he was fed misinformation
so these are two sides of the coin which
are super interesting I think if you can
look at them with your own biased turned
off and not have a desired outcome I
want to believe this I don't want to
believe this right speaking of I want to
believe you know I was working on a
project with Chris Carter the who is the
x-files creator and the one person I
took the source that I wanted to meet
the source was Chris Carter and I we
went out there together and sat with him
and met him and it was well because the
source had never even heard of the
x-files that it was like oh I know
probably me talking about baseball you
know really yeah